- Hi, everyone. Good afternoon.
I am Priya Natarajan.
I am the current director of
the Franke Program in
Science and the Humanities,
and I'm delighted to invite you all today
for our colloquium, Understanding
the Nature of Inference.
This has been a series, as you all know,
that we have had
since the past year,
and I want to start this afternoon
by first thanking and
recognizing the generosity
of Mr. and Mrs. Richard and Barbara Franke
and who have funded the Franke Program
and many other interdisciplinary
activities at Yale.
I want to remind the audience
that because this event is being recorded,
all videos and microphones will be muted,
and as per custom, we request
you to submit questions
in the Q&A feature of the webinar.
As you all know, the inference,
understanding the inference,
Nature of Inference
series, colloquium series
is one in which we have
been looking deeply
at the process of inference
across disciplines
with a real view to understand the utility
of conceptual models, simulations,
arguments that are
particular to a discipline
but transcend and teach
us something more profound
about the notion of causation, inference,
and cause and effect,
as well as correlation.
As you know, we've assembled
a core group of experts
across intellectual disciplines
ranging from epidemiology,
cosmology, genetics,
organizational behavior,
climate modeling, and to
today's speaker, philosophy.
Today's speaker, I'm absolutely
delighted to introduce him,
Professor Alex Paseau,
who is a professor of
philosophy at Oxford,
and it is a particular pleasure for me
because he is also a very good friend,
and so inference is
a logical philosophical term
that Professor Paseau will show us
has been used to describe the process
of deriving conclusions from premises,
and the conclusion drawn from the premises
is what we refer to as inference.
In this talk, he will
explore the mathematical
and philosophical aspects of inference,
and the word infer means to
deduce or draw a conclusion
from the evidence that's provided,
and it's the process of using logic
to come up with a conclusion.
There are two types of inferences,
deductive and non-deductive inferences.
So he will be delving into
the two kinds of inferences
and showing us the domain of validity
of these two forms of
inference, and in particular,
he is going to be showing
us that mathematics
has a very long tradition
of using formal reasoning,
but some mathematicians have
argued that there's a need
for non-deductive reasoning in the field.
So mathematics has always been
considered an exact science,
but in the last century, it
is seen as more of an art
with many different multiple
approaches for problems.
So in today's talk,
Professor Paseau will present
some of his ideas about
non-deductive reasoning
in mathematics and explain why,
contrary to popular belief,
it can be actually a source of knowledge
as well as justified belief,
but before I turn over the floor to him,
let me give you a formal introduction.
Alexander Paseau read mathematics,
followed by a year of philosophy part two
at Trinity College, Cambridge,
and after taking his BPhil
in philosophy at Oxford,
he returned to Cambridge for his PhD.
He spent 2001 as a visiting
graduate student at Princeton.
After three years of a research fellowship
at Jesus College, Cambridge,
he moved to Oxford in 2005,
where he's now a professor and
a fellow of Wadham College.
He has been an associate
editor of the journal "Mind"
and has had research fellowships
from the Mind Association
and the Leverhulme Trust,
as well as visiting appointments
at the Sydney Centre for
the Foundations of Science,
King's College London,
and the Institut d'histoire
et de philosophie
des sciences and techniques in Paris.
So as is usual, we will
have the colloquium today,
and tomorrow, we will
continue with a conversation
with Professor Sher of the
University of California,
San Diego, who will be talking to Alex
and interacting with all
of you in the audience
tomorrow at the same time,
but before I
turn it over to Alex,
I just want to quickly mention
that we have a virtual talk,
this is upcoming Franke events,
we have a virtual talk by
the journalist Esther Honig
on Wednesday, November 16th,
and we have an in-person
talk by the architect
and NASA engineer James
Ramsey on November 10th,
and we will have our next
Nature of Inference colloquium
talk given by the computer
scientist Brian Cantwell Smith.
So without further ado,
Alex, the floor is yours
and we are absolutely delighted
to have you speak here today.
- Thank you very much,
Priya, for that warm welcome.
I'm extremely pleased to be here
and to be able to discuss with you
and share with a broader
audience some ideas.
It's been 20 years since we
were part of a discussion group
just out of grad school
and it's very nice to sort of repeat that.
I'd also like to thank the funders too.
So my topic today is inference
from a logical and
philosophical perspective.
I work primarily in the philosophy
of mathematics and logic,
so that is effectively my perspective
that I'll be describing, and
I'll introduce the topic,
give you some references,
and then focus on two topics.
First, the idea that logic is infinite,
and secondly on non-deductive
inference reasoning
in mathematics and maybe
speculate at the end
on the link between the two.
So let's begin by distinguishing,
as Priya already did,
just to follow up on that between logical
and non-logical inference.
So what is the difference between the two?
Well, let's have an example.
The first inference that I
wanna mention is the following.
All horses are ungulates,
all ungulates are mammals,
so all horses are mammals.
Okay, now you, I hope,
will recognize this to be a
formal, a valid inference,
that is to say the conclusion
follows from the premises.
If the premises are true,
then the conclusion also has to be true,
and the interesting thing
about this inference
is it instantiates a formal
pattern, a formal schema.
All As are Bs, all Bs
are Cs, so all As are Cs,
and you can see that any
instance of that is valid,
and in fact, in order to recognize
the validity of the argument,
you don't have to know what any
of the adjectives there mean
or any of the words like horses
and ungulates and mammals mean.
I try this out regularly
on my first-year students.
I show them this argument and I ask them
whether the premises
make the conclusion true,
or if the premises are true,
does that mean that the
conclusion has to be true?
And they all recognize
that the argument is valid.
They all recognize that
the truth of the premises
necessitates the truth of
the conclusion, even though,
and then I've asked them
a follow-up question,
even though most of them do not know
what the word ungulate means.
That just highlights, I think,
the fact that we can recognize
this argument to be valid
just in virtue of the form,
whatever the word ungulate means.
The counterpart to logical inference
is non-logical inference.
So just to give us a
simple example of this,
previous samples have boiled
at 100 degrees Celsius,
so this one also will.
So that's non-logical.
The conclusion does not
follow from the premise,
the single premise there necessarily,
and it's not formal.
If you schematize it,
if you turn it into formal letters there,
you say previous As have been
Bs, so the next A will be a B.
You can see that that can be
a good inference in some cases
but will not invariably
be a good inference.
For example, if you've rolled
a die a couple of times
and it's been a six both times,
then to infer that it will be a six
the next time you throw it
has a one in six chance of being true,
so certainly not a valid argument.
Okay, so that's the difference
between logical and non-logical inference.
How would we characterize
logical inference?
Many would define it as follows:
necessary truth-preservation
in virtue of form.
The conclusion follows
necessarily from the premises
in virtue of the form, as
in the ungulates argument,
and a mathematical proof,
and I'm gonna focus on mathematics later,
so it's a particular interest to me,
a mathematical proof is a
logically valid argument
from some axioms,
and this is a fact that's
come to be appreciated
in the past 100, 120 years or so.
That's to say you can turn
any mathematical argument
into a logical argument from the axioms
of that particular area of mathematics,
or perhaps more broadly, the
axioms of all of mathematics,
and reasoning in science and everyday life
and also in mathematics has both logical
and non-logical aspects.
Sometimes we don't notice
it in everyday life,
but we do use logically valid arguments,
but we also often argue
in a non-logical way.
However, mathematics
is somewhat exceptional
in that there a claim is
regarded as established
only if it has been proved.
It's only a result if it's been proved.
In other spheres of intellectual activity
in other walks of life,
you can establish a result,
a claim without proving
it in a strict sense,
but in mathematics a
claim is only regarded
as really established if it's been proved
and it becomes a theorem.
So I wanna talk about
both forms of validity
and my claim about logic
and stake out two claims,
one per form of validity.
The claim about logical validity
that I want to examine is
whether logic is finite.
Okay, and this is actually a sort of
a tenet of contemporary thought,
or to put it sort of
pejoratively, a dogma,
and I will argue instead
that logical validity
can be infinite.
What it means for logic
to be finite or infinite
I will clarify shortly.
The other sort of tenet is
about non-logical validity,
is, in mathematics at least,
that this is sort of second rate.
The best form of argument
is, as I mentioned,
logical or deductive you might say,
and in mathematics, anything
that doesn't meet that standard
in some sense doesn't cut the
mustard, and so in particular,
a non-logical inference
cannot provide knowledge
of a mathematical claim.
Okay, so those are the two top,
the two theses I'm going to talk about
and try to argue against,
giving some reasons for my views.
Gonna give you some references here
on the logical validity side of things.
This idea that logic is infinite
that I'll be describing and defending,
there are some pioneers in the field
on whose work I'm building.
The first is Alfred Tarski,
who in a 1966 lecture that
was posthumously published
in 1986 first developed the
idea that logic is infinite,
to put it broadly speaking,
and then there's Gila Sher,
who I'm very pleased is with us today
and who will be my discussant tomorrow,
and in her work building on Tarski,
she has also developed this
idea ranging from an early book,
"The Bounds of Logic" in
'91 to her most recent book,
very recent, in fact,
"Logical Consequence,"
and my contribution to this debate,
to this domain has been most recently
in the monograph "One True Logic"
co-written with Owen Griffiths,
which came out a few months ago.
That's on the logical validity side,
and then the sort of references on the,
if you wanna do some
further reading on this,
on the non-logical
reasoning side of things,
there's a classic mid
20th century classics
classic by George Polya called
"Mathematics and Plausible Reasoning,"
and that came out in the '50s and '60s.
More recent and more
philosophical engagement
has been by Don Fallis
in a couple of articles,
and I've cited one of mine from 2015.
Okay, so those are the references
if anyone wants to do
some follow-up reading.
So let's move to the first big idea
that logic is not, as sort
of current thinking has it,
finite but is in fact infinite.
Okay, so the first thing
we need to get clear on is
what it means for logic
to be finite or infinite.
Okay, so a logic is in many ways
like an ordinary language, right?
Such as pick your favorite
ordinary natural language,
ordinary language, English,
Arabic, Spanish, Mandarin.
Philosophers, by the
way, as I already did,
call these natural languages
in distinction to logic.
The language of a logic
contains some vocabulary
and it also contains rules
for stringing together the vocabulary.
Call that a grammar.
That's true of a natural
language such as English as well.
So let's give two examples of
grammatical rules for English.
So if A and B are sentences,
then their conjunction,
A and B, is a sentence.
So for example, if "Fido
is a dog" is a sentence
and "Felix is a cat" is a sentence,
then so is the sentence "Fido
a dog and Felix is a cat."
That's called their disjunction,
and if A and B are sentences,
then so is their disjunction.
That's when you join them
together by the word or,
and to say that that logic is finite,
just to put it very roughly,
is to say that all the
sentences are of finite length,
but in contrast, an infinite
logic allows you to conjoin,
join with and, or disjoin, join with or,
infinitely many sentences
and to quantify over
infinitely many variables.
So you can say there
exists not just one X,
there exists X, there
exists Y, there exists Z,
but you can quantify over
infinitely many variables.
Okay, and I'll explain that
a bit more as we go along.
Infinite logics have been a minor area
of mathematical study since the 1950s,
but they're not generally
regarded as correct,
as capturing correct form of implication.
The usual term here, by the way,
in the field is finitary
versus infinitary,
but for the purposes of this talk,
I'm gonna just use the
simpler finite and infinite.
So the argument for the infinity of logic
is to my mind made up of
two sorts of considerations.
There's what I call the
bottom-up arguments,
and these rest on relatively
light theoretical principles.
You don't need a great deal of theory
or theoretical commitments
to accept these.
They sort of rest on things
that most people believe
about logic already or
slight extensions of them.
The top-down arguments
are much more theoretical.
They're based on the nature of logic
and/or the logical constants.
What are the logical constants?
That won't be that relevant
today, but they are,
just to clarify that they're expressions
such as and or there exists,
and those are dealt with,
the two sorts of arguments are discussed
in respective chapters
of my recent monograph.
Okay, so let's look at an argument.
Let's consider this following argument.
It consists of the premise
there is at least one planet,
a second premise, there
are at least two planets,
third premise, there are
at least three planets,
and so on for all finite numbers.
So it has infinitely many premises
and then it has a conclusion
and that's drawn below the line.
The conclusion is there are
infinitely many planets.
Okay, so if we think about that argument,
this argument seems valid in some sense.
That's to say the premises
necessitate the conclusion, okay?
If the premises, or put it another way,
if the premises are true,
the conclusion must be true,
because if there's at least
one planet, at least two,
at least three, at least four and so on,
then there's gotta be
infinitely many, okay?
And the question is whether
it's logically valid or not.
Okay, so my claim, which I will
not be able to defend here,
but I will just state,
is that this argument is
in fact logically valid.
One can show that it's logically valid
or one can argue that it is.
The second claim is that standard logic,
which is finite, cannot capture it, okay?
And this is actually quite
an easy claim to establish,
that the standard logic,
which is first-order logic,
cannot capture this
argument as logically valid,
because, briefly,
if in first-order logic,
in standard logic,
if there's an argument with
infinitely many premises
and a conclusion, it's a valid argument,
there's also gotta be a sub-argument
made up of finitely many of those premises
that entails the conclusion,
and clearly, if you just have
finite many of those premises,
you know that there are, say, two planets,
at least two planets, at least 53,
at least 412 up to some finite number,
then it doesn't follow that
there are infinitely many.
The third claim is that
other finite logics
cannot capture this
argument's generalizations,
and the fourth claim is
that an infinite logic can.
So this is what I call a
bottom-up argument, right?
In order to capture the
validity of this argument,
assuming it is logically
valid, and that's claim one,
you need effectively what the argument is
is that you need a infinite logic.
A finite logic isn't gonna cut it.
It's not gonna be able to capture
the validity of this argument.
Let me give another example of
another consideration on
the sort of bottom-up side.
Consider this argument here,
and the reason I wanna
give another argument
is to make it look a little
bit less mathematical,
less to do with numbers.
Bob is not my parent. Bob
is not my grandparent.
Bob is not my great
grandparent and so on, okay?
You keep on iterating the greats.
Therefore, Bob is not my ancestor.
Now, this argument is not formally valid.
If you change the word
parent in all the premises,
so in the word in the first premise,
turn it into, say, child,
turn the word parent in the second premise
to child to make it grandchild and so on,
then the conclusion will not follow.
So it's not a formally valid argument.
It's not just valid in virtue of form,
but if we add the meaning premise,
we can make the argument formally valid,
and the meaning premise
here is the premise
about the meaning of the word ancestor,
and what's the relevant idea?
Well, you're my ancestor
if you are my parent
or grandparent or
great-grandparent or so on, okay?
So this is a list that
continues ad infinitum,
and if we add that premise,
then the argument becomes formally valid
and can be captured in an infinite logic.
So just to give you a sense of
what an infinite logic looks like,
the sentences of an
infinite logic look like,
the formalization of this Bob argument
plus the meaning premise
would look like this.
The first premise would
get formalized as not P1b.
That's to be understood as
Bob is not my parent, right?
So the first symbol there is a not sign,
P1 means is my parent, and
b can be understood as Bob,
not Bob, the second premise,
Bob is not my grandparent and so on,
and the meaning premise which
we've added is that for all x,
x is an ancestor if and only if,
that double arrow can be
read as if and only if,
some, that thing, that
x is either my parent
or my grandparent or my
great-grandparent and so on,
and notice that that big V
sign, it's a big disjunction,
is infinite, right?
You need to disjoin infinitely
many formulas there.
So that's the sense in which that formula,
that logic is infinite, and from that,
the conclusion follows that
Bob is not my ancestor.
Okay, so that's the,
these are the sorts of bottom-up arguments
that one can develop further
to argue that logic should be infinite.
Another sort of bottom-up argument,
it consists of a sort of-
- [Priya] Alex, I have a quick question.
- [Alex] Yes.
- [Priya] So that rests on the fact
that you have an infinite layered
set of relationships, right?
- You have an infinite
premise set, correct.
- [Priya] Right. Okay.
- Yeah, actually, that's
very relevant to something
that I'll mention in a
couple of, in a few slides.
Thank you, Priya.
So the thought experiment
imagines the following sort of being,
a superhuman who can
accomplish supertasks.
These are infinite tasks
that can be completed
in a finite amount of time, okay?
So a superhuman is capable of uttering
an infinitely long sentence,
such as the following,
0 is even and 2 is even
and 4 is even and so on.
So for every even number,
that claim that that number is even
gets included in the sentence.
How does a superhuman do it?
Well, they utter 0 is even in one second,
then they speed up.
They say n2 is even in 1/2 a second.
They say n4 is even in 1/4
of a second, and so on,
so that after two seconds,
they've uttered an infinitely
long sentence, okay?
Now, superhumans, we do not think exist.
They're not biologically
possible, perhaps.
Perhaps they're physically
possible, perhaps they're not.
The important point here is
that they're certainly
conceptually possible.
There's nothing sort of conceptually wrong
with assuming that they could exist,
even if they don't actually exist.
So suppose that superhumans perform
the following sort of inference.
They utter this infinitely long premise
and then they utter another
infinitely long sentence,
again using speed up, but
this one's a little different.
They say zero is even, n4 is
even, n8 is even, and so on.
So what they do in uttering the conclusion
is they drop every other
clause in the premise.
They drop the 2 is even clause
and 6 is even clause
and 10 is even and so on
and they just say the multiples of 4.
Okay, so I think, so
this looks very much like
a sort of inference that logicians think
is completely fine in the finite case.
You know, if you have A and B
and from that you infer that A,
clearly that's completely
fine and that's valid,
but in this case there's a twist
because we have an infinitely long premise
and an infinitely long conclusion.
So it's an infinite form of
what logicians call
conjunction elimination.
You have a conjunction and you eliminate
some of the conjuncts and
this looks just as valid
as a finite form of
conjunction elimination, okay?
And you might say in response to this,
"Well, this inference is something
that we can describe in finite terms."
I've just done this in
giving you the slide
and talking about it, but actually,
we've gotta imagine the superhumans
actually carrying out the inference, okay?
We can come back to that in
the questions if you like,
but that's the sort of thought experiment
that is supposed to
make more vivid the idea
that if finite logic is,
a standard finite logic is logic,
then why not go further and think
that an infinite logic is also logic?
Okay, so there are more bottom-up
arguments than the above,
but it's time I think for a
sort of important clarification,
and here I must confess to something.
I have to fess up to something.
I labeled my talk
Inference: A
Logical-Philosophical Perspective,
but actually in this part of the talk,
I'm talking about implication
rather than inference,
strictly speaking, and
what is the difference?
Implication is really a relation
between sentences, okay?
Something that holds from
between some premises
and a conclusion or premise set,
if you like, and a conclusion,
and it's a fact that
holds between sentences
and it's not anthropocentric.
So in the ungulates argument,
whether the premises entail the conclusion
is not something that we do.
It's just the fact about those sentences.
Inference, on the other hand,
is something that an agent performs, okay?
And it is an anthropocentric notion
because an agent reasons from
premises to a conclusion.
Even if we consider idealized agents,
that's still a sort of
anthropocentric notion, okay?
Even, for example, if we think
about Bayesian epistemology,
about Bayesian reasoners who are idealized
in some sense, in some ways,
that still is a form of inference,
and logic's main role is, I think,
I believe, to capture implication.
It captures the relations
between sentences.
How does it relate to inference?
Well, the study of
inference and rationality
is informed by logic, but it
doesn't boil down to logic.
So let me give you an example
of what I mean by that.
So suppose you believe A, some
fact A, and you ask yourself,
"What else should I think if I believe A?"
Well, then you might come to appreciate
the fact that A logically
implies B, right?
This is a fact about
sentences, that A implies B,
but whether you then go on to believe B
isn't determined entirely by the fact
that A logically implies B.
You may think that B, you
may find B very implausible,
and you may think, "Hang on, I believed A.
I now realize that A implies
B, but B is very implausible,
so maybe I should have
another think about A.
Maybe I should not believe A," okay?
So there may be all sorts of rational ways
to react to implication facts
and implication facts
aren't gonna determine
all inferential facts.
So implication captures
facts about sentences,
and inferences, facts
about what reasoners do.
Okay, so having said that,
we can ask what language
applied logicians or logicians
who think about using logic
to capture reasonings,
as in the to capture
our arguments couched in language,
such as the ungulates argument
or the planets argument
or the Bob argument I gave earlier,
what language are we
actually interested in here?
So I've given these arguments in English,
but actually, the choice
of a particular language,
such as English, for
example, a natural language,
even if you understand a language
to include all the
technical vocabulary, right?
So when I say the
examples I've given so far
have mostly been sort of
homely bits of vocabulary,
you know, about planets,
about horses and mammals,
about Bob being my ancestor
or not, that sort of thing,
but you can throw in all the
sort of technical vocabulary
of the sciences, of mathematics,
of the law, and so on, so on,
but the choice of any
such language would be,
as the sort of focus,
this central focus of a logician's study,
would be somewhat parochial.
Why is that? Well, because
natural languages sort of grow.
They accrue words by the day.
Just to take an example, "I
can't play my DVD on my laptop."
Well, that would've been
incomprehensible to Victorians.
Okay, so it would be quite
odd to give an account
of logical implication that
just applied to English
as it is today on the
28th of September, 2022.
That would seem too parochial,
too narrow a project.
The logician should really be interested
not in any particular natural language,
including the technical parts,
as it is today but in
its extensions as well,
and once we appreciate this fact,
that opens the door to generalizations
of the bottom-up arguments
that go beyond the countably infinite,
that's to say that go beyond the infinity
of the natural numbers
0, 1, 2, 3, and so on.
Okay, so that's so much for
the bottom-up arguments.
So they strongly point to the conclusion
that logic cannot be finite
but must be infinite.
Now let's move on to the
other type of argument
for the infinity of logic and
this is a top-down argument
about the nature of logic.
So what is the nature of logic?
Well, two features of logic
that are generally accepted
are generality and topic neutrality.
Generality is the idea that
logic applies to all spheres,
and topic neutrality, a
very closely related idea,
is that it doesn't have a topic of its own
but rather it applies to all areas.
So for example, mathematics
is about numbers
and functions and shapes in geometry,
and physics might study particles,
economics, rational economic behavior,
be it of idealized agents or
actual economies and so on.
These all have topics,
but logic is topic neutral is the idea,
and the logician that I mentioned earlier,
famous 20th century logician Tarski,
he made this idea of
topic neutrality precise
by considering permutations.
So if you look, consider the set A, B, C
and a permutation mapping
A to B, B to C, and C to A,
think of that permutation.
It's just shuffling the elements around.
Well, some sets, such as the set A, B, C,
is mapped to itself by
this permutation, okay?
Some sets are mapped to
themselves by the permutation.
They're invariant under it
because A gets mapped to B,
B to C, C to A, but others are not.
For example, A, B is mapped to the other,
a distinct set, B and C,
because A gets mapped to B and B to C.
So it's variant under the permutation,
and if you think of properties
and relations as sets
and define what it is for
a property or relation
to be permutation invariant,
then you can get a
notion applying to these
of variants applying to these
properties or relations,
so for example, the
property being American
and the property being self-identical.
If you think about all the eight billion,
almost eight billion
people on the planet today,
a small subset of those are American.
So if you permute the eight billion people
on the planet today and you map
some Americans to some non-Americans,
then the property the set
of the Americans changes.
However, the property
of being self-identical
is a property that's had
by absolutely everyone
on the planet, okay?
So however you permute
the people on the planet,
the set of people on the planet,
that property is not gonna change.
It's gonna be the set of all people, okay?
And that aligns with sort
of intuitive judgments
that being American is
not a logical property,
but being self-identical
is a logical property.
Now, there's a complication
here because being human,
for example, on the domain
of all people alive today,
as I said, the almost
eight billion people,
well, that will be
permutation invariant as well,
because however you permute
them, they're all human,
so the set of human beings over this
is gonna stay fixed over
the world's population,
but like being American, being
human is not topic neutral.
So Gila Sher had the
idea, the correct idea,
that to remove all
sensitivity to subject matter,
we must consider not just
permutations of a domain
but bijections to others of the same size.
That's to say you map them to
other sets of the same size.
So you've got the almost
eight billion people,
the domain of all of the
inhabitants of the planet today.
You can map those almost
eight billion people to,
say, the natural numbers,
and then being human is not
preserved under that mapping,
and the technical name for this,
which I will not use but
I want to say nonetheless,
is isomorphism invariance,
and the theorem proved by
Vann McGee links this notion
of invariance to the infinity of logic.
So roughly a property or
relation of the right type
is invariant just when it's
expressible by a formula of,
and this is how this is
pronounced, L infinity infinity,
and this logic, L infinity infinity,
is in a sense as infinite as can be,
highly, highly infinite logic.
So a more technical explanation would be
to say that it extends standard logic
by allowing for any,
any, any cardinal kappa,
it's the Greek letter kappa,
conjunctions and disjunctions
of kappa-many disjuncts,
conjuncts or disjuncts respectively
and allowing quantification
over kappa-many argument places.
So to properly appreciate this,
you have to know that there are
lots of different sizes of infinity,
and what this is saying is actually
for whatever size of
infinity you pick, you,
the logic L infinity infinity is as large,
at least as large as that.
So just to, because this
was somewhat more technical,
this last idea, the sort
of the top-down argument,
I wanna summarize it.
How does it start?
It starts from the
characterization of logic
as being topic neutral, okay?
And topic neutrality,
and this is something
that's generally agreed,
topic neutrality can be
more precisely understood
as the notion of invariance
that I described, okay?
That's a more precise way of spelling out
and it's a precise way of spelling out
this notion of topic neutrality,
and it turns out that this
notion of invariance coincides
with what can be characterized
in a highly infinite logic.
So the upshot is that we've
got a top-down argument
for the infinity of logic.
If you ask, "What is logic?"
the answer is it's topic neutral.
You spell that out and it
turns out, on that basis,
you get an argument that logic
is not just infinite but highly infinite,
and so these two sorts of
arguments actually converge.
They point to the same conclusion.
The top-down and the bottom-up arguments
point to the conclusion that
logic is highly infinite,
which in today's climate
is quite a radical thought
because up until fairly
recently, I mean, until today,
logic is almost universally
regarded as being finite, okay?
And yet I believe, as I have sketched,
that there are good reasons
to think that it's infinite,
both top-down about the nature
of logic and bottom-up about,
which rest on much less
theoretical considerations
about logic.
Okay, so that was the
logic side of things,
and then the last third
of the talk will be about
non-deductive inference in mathematics,
and here I will talk
squarely about inference,
and this is the other side of the coin.
The implication/inference distinction
that I mentioned earlier will
not be very important here,
and usually when applied to mathematics,
this may be called informal
or non-deductive inference or reasoning.
So I'll switch between
those ways of speaking.
Okay, so just to motivate this,
let's think a little bit
about this simple example.
Suppose, let's say, you're
a high school student
and you're sort of playing around
with the odd numbers, okay?
And you notice a pattern, okay?
You notice that 1, well,
of course that's 1 squared.
Then you add 1 plus 3, 1 and
3 and you get 4, so 2 squared.
1 plus 3 plus 5, you notice a 3 squared.
1 plus 3 plus 5 plus 7 is 4 squared,
and this is news to you, you know?
You're not a mathematical whiz.
You're a high school student
who's never encountered this before,
and so you form the conjecture
that the sum of the first
n odd numbers is n squared,
and then you might test
quite a few more cases.
You might test them by hand.
Maybe you'll, you know some coding,
so you'll program a computer
to test the first billion cases
and they all turn out to
verify this conjecture,
but do you know it?
Do you know the conjecture
even if you check the first billion cases?
And I think the answer's
a clear no, right?
What you have is some good
but very partial evidence,
and in particular, you
lack a proof, right?
Until you prove the claim, it's
a very easy claim to prove,
but we're assuming the high school student
has not proved it at that point.
When they haven't proved it,
just noticed the pattern,
even for the first billion cases,
they do not know the claim.
They lack a proof.
Okay, now, there are mathematically
much more interesting examples
where we have more evidence,
and not just a little bit more evidence,
but a lot more evidence,
and the example I wanna give you
is that of Goldbach's
conjecture, call it GC,
and it dates from 1742 in a letter
by Christian Goldbach to Leonhard Euler.
It states that every even
number greater than 2
is the sum of two primes.
Okay, so here's an example.
6 is 3 plus 3 and that's the only way
you can write 6 as the sum of two primes.
3 is of course prime,
or you can write 100,
or to take 100, you can
write that as 97 plus 3.
That's one way of doing it for 100.
Another way would be 53 plus 47
and then there are lots of other ways.
The interesting thing about
Goldbach's conjecture,
despite the fact that it was conjectured
almost 300 years ago,
it's currently unproved,
but another interesting fact
about Goldbach's conjecture
is that we have a lot, a
lot of evidence for it.
So let me just run through
some of the evidence,
not all of it.
This is by no means an exhaustive list.
The conjecture has been
checked for every even number
up to 4 times 10 to the 18, right?
So a lot more than 10,
than a billion cases.
We also know it's also been proved
that every sufficiently large even number
is the sum of two numbers though.
The first is a prime and the
second number is either a prime
or the product of two primes.
So that's getting very
close to the conjecture,
and that fact has been proved.
It's also been proved, and
this was actually in the 2010s,
that every odd number is
the sum of three primes.
Again, very close to the
conjecture, slightly weaker claim.
It's also been proved that every number
is the sum of no more than six primes.
Okay, the Goldbach's conjecture, remember,
says that it's exactly two.
I mean, you can do it with just two.
So again, this is a weaker claim,
but that's also been proved.
We also know in, for the
cases that we know about,
for the up to the 4
times 10 to the 18 cases,
not actually all of those
but quite a lot of those,
number of ways that an
even number can be written
as a sum of two primes sort of
non-monotonically increases.
It doesn't increase in a
sort of monotonic fashion
just going straight up, but you know,
a bit like a currency
sort of strengthening,
sort of goes up and down a little bit
but with a kind of
underlying growing trend.
So for example, in the case of 6,
we saw that 6 can be
written in just one way
as the sum of two primes, 3
plus 3, but 100 can be written,
we gave at least two ways of doing it,
and it can be written quite a few,
as the sum of two primes
in quite a few ways,
and in fact, when you get to a number
even as small as about 10,000,
that number can be written
as the sum of two primes
in hundreds of ways, which
makes it very implausible
that somehow this is
going to sort of crash
from being able to write a number
as a sum of several hundred,
in several hundred ways
as a sum of two primes,
the next even number,
somehow it's gonna crash
and go down to to zero.
It's a plausibility argument.
It's not a proof, but that is the thought.
There's also heuristic argument
using the Prime Number Theorem,
and the Prime Number
Theorem tells you about
the distribution of primes
up to a particular N,
tells you roughly how many
numbers smaller than N are prime,
and it also, there's
an argument based on it
that strongly supports the idea
that Goldbach's conjecture is true.
It doesn't prove it.
It's based on how many numbers
smaller than N are prime,
and if you look at the
sums of these numbers,
of these prime numbers, well,
according to this heuristic argument,
every typical integer that's
smaller or equal to 2N
should be writeable as
the sum of two primes
in sort of about N over
2 log N squared ways.
So in other words,
that should grow as N
gets bigger and bigger,
and that's not a proof, but
it's a heuristic argument
from the sort of
distribution of the primes.
It's also been proved
that the counterexamples,
the density tends to 0.
That's to say at any given point,
if you look at how many
numbers up to that point
might be counterexamples
to the Goldbach conjecture,
well, that ratio is gonna
definitely provably tend to 0,
and there's more evidence
for Goldbach's conjecture.
So as I say, lots of very strong evidence
for the truth of Goldbach's conjecture
that does not add up to a proof,
and quite varied sort of evidence too,
proofs of closely related
results, numerical evidence,
heuristic arguments and so on,
and there are lots of other
interesting conjectures
in mathematics today.
One is the, probably the most
famous unproved conjecture in,
unproved statement in mathematics,
the Riemann hypothesis.
You know, you'd have
to be more of an expert
on that area of mathematics than I am
to cite the evidence carefully there,
and there are other sorts of arguments
that are non-deductive in mathematics.
Another well-known one
is primality testing,
for example, the Rabin-Miller test,
and this, the way this test works is
you put forward a number N,
a natural and a whole number N
and then you run a test on
it to see whether it's prime,
and you can do this several times,
and every time you do it,
the result is, the claim,
the verdict of whether
it's prime or not prime
is independent of the previous
one if the number is prime,
and so if you run the test 1,000
times with different inputs
and 1,000 times the test
says that N is prime,
then it's provable, it's provably the case
that N is prime with this probability,
a probability at least
1 minus 1/4 to 1,000,
and that's just running
the test 1,000 times.
Of course you can run it a lot more times
and increase the exponent there.
Now, 1 minus 1/4 to the 1,000
is extremely close to 1, right?
It's a degree of
confidence in N's primality
that outstrips almost everything,
any evidence that we have
with respect to anything
in ordinary life and also in science.
So we can be extremely, extremely
confident that N is prime.
It's not a proof that N is prime,
but it's a proof that N is prime
with extremely, extremely
high probability.
Okay.
So by all normal and even
scientific standards,
the evidence for the Goldbach conjecture
is extraordinarily strong,
but most mathematicians
nonetheless would say
that we don't know Goldbach's conjecture,
even the ones who have all the evidence,
that's to say number theorists
who know this evidence
about the conjecture.
So I wanna suggest that actually
they're wrong about this.
That in some cases,
and probably in the case
of Goldbach's conjecture,
and I'm gonna stick my neck out,
we do know the truth of the claim,
and what are the sorts of
considerations we can run here?
Well, in the interests of time,
I'm just gonna state them.
I'm not gonna go into them in any detail.
The first consideration is actually
that deduction doesn't have any sort of
special epistemological virtue.
So people have thought that
deduction preserves certainty.
If you're certain of the premise,
you should also be
certain of the conclusion,
so there's something special
in that sense about deduction,
but I don't think there's
good reason to think that,
and just to run through
the second, the others,
if you look at the sort
of analyses of knowledge
in philosophy and
epistemology, they allow,
they either allow for non-deductive
knowledge of mathematics
or they just do not apply
to the case of mathematics.
So general philosophers who
are not particularly interested
in the philosophy of
mathematics have come up
with conditions on knowledge.
They don't seem to rule
out non-deductive knowledge
of mathematics is the argument,
the second consideration,
and the third consideration,
that the axioms are the
foundation, are also justified,
are often justified in
terms of their consequences.
So it would be a bit odd
to justify some axioms
of the foundation of mathematics,
which is usually taken to be set theory,
in terms of their consequences
that are typically more like
scientific sort of evidence,
non-deductive evidence,
but then insist that in order to know
anything in mathematics,
they must be provable from those axioms
which are justified in this
sort of non-deductive way,
and a fourth sort of consideration
is that there are strong links between
the mathematical and the physical.
You can know applied mathematical facts
by observation and testing.
You know, you might be able to know
what the mean of a
distribution is by sampling.
You might be able to,
you'd be able to work out some facts
about geometrical facts by, for example,
doing experiments on physical triangles.
You might know numerical
facts by looking at clusters
of physical objects and
so on, and in those cases,
I think we very clearly want to say
that in the physical
case, we know those facts,
but then because they
sort of are analogous
to mathematical facts,
it'll be strange to say
that we know the physical facts.
They have corresponding
mathematical facts,
but yet we don't know those
corresponding mathematical facts
if we haven't proved them.
Okay, so I realized I've run
through those fairly quickly,
but that's because I want to wrap up,
and just very briefly as my last slide,
what is the link between the two things
that I've talked about, okay?
So remember the first,
my first argument was
that logic is infinite,
against the sort of tenet
of contemporary thought
that logic is finite, and
the second one was that,
strictly about inference this time,
that mathematical inference
is not as bad as it might seem
and in fact can lead to knowledge.
So maybe, I'm not entirely sure myself,
but maybe what links them
is a sort of permissiveness
about inference and about implication,
and my claims are that there's much more
to logic than recognized.
It's infinite, and in fact.
even highly infinite rather than finite,
and that non-logical inference can be
more reliable than is often appreciated,
and even in mathematics where
the deductive method reigns,
it should be recognized as
giving rise to knowledge.
So thank you very much. That's it.
- Great. Thank you so much, Alex.
That was absolutely brilliant.
We can now open up the floor to questions.
Are there any questions?
Please go ahead and
type in your questions.
I'll just give people a couple of minutes
to get their bearings.
So if I may, (laughing) I may start,
so what is special about
the structure of mathematics?
Obviously this is a big question,
but there is something about,
isn't there something about
the structure of mathematics
that there is an inherent
provable self-consistency
that you can demonstrate, right,
say compared to, say, physics?
- Yeah. Okay, thank you.
I think what makes mathematics special
is that it's so abstract,
that it's about structure in general.
So for example, it might
be about the structure
of the natural numbers or it
might be the real numbers,
but those can be described
in very abstract terms
and they may have physical
instantiations or not,
and that means because
we can characterize them
in this very abstract way,
then we can use abstract
arguments to discuss them
and therefore makes the sort
of deductive method possible
because you're just looking
at characterizing axioms.
- Right.
- [Alex] And that's all it takes
to understand the structure.
- Right,
and the structure and
the sort of relationships
between objects, mathematical objects,
are somehow, they are more,
they are not,
they cannot be perturbed
by experimentation, right?
So the analog that you have in physics,
that you have a system,
especially, you know,
quantum mechanics is
obviously the dramatic case,
where, you know, the act
of making an observation
alters the system itself, right?
So there is something
about the stability, right,
of mathematical objects that permits you
to make these logical arguments.
There's something about the fixity, right?
So...
- Yeah, absolutely.
So I don't, I think there isn't
any sort of observer interference
of any kind in the mathematical case,
and I mean that's, so
in the physical case,
as you mentioned, there
is that famous instance,
and of course it's a major
problem in social science
that our role as theorists,
social scientists who are theorists
are involved in the
actual swirl of human life
and therefore can affect it.
So there isn't that sort
of feedback in any way
and that maybe is one reason why
that makes it sort of
cleaner and easier to study.
- Cleaner, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I think we have a
question from Peter Morgan.
What is the role of the axiom of choice
in this kind of infinite logic?
For the superhuman example,
what difference does it make
if the superhuman misses out
a non-procedurally determined
set of multiples of 2,
if there's a gap, right?
- Thank you very much, Peter Morgan.
That's an excellent question.
So the example that I
gave of the superhumans
can be stated and fleshed out
without using the axiom of choice,
because you can say it,
you can specify the rule that I gave.
The inference that I mentioned
can be described quite simply.
You're just missing out the multiples of 2
that are not multiples of 4.
So you don't need the axiom of choice
for that particular example.
To answer the second
part of your question,
what difference would it make
if a superhuman misses out
a non-procedurally determined
set of multiples of 2,
yes, in that case, in order to imagine
an inference of that sort,
you might have to invoke
the axiom of choice,
depending on what is actually omitted,
but the idea doesn't rely on it.
It does not rely on the axiom of choice
because you can just
describe it more simply
in the way that I do.
- The next question is from Kasavan,
and is the claim here that
the high degree of certainty
is or perhaps should be sufficient
for mathematical knowledge?
- Okay, Kasavan. Yes, thank you.
No. My answer to that is no.
I don't think high degree
of certainty is enough.
I don't think that's
necessarily true in any sphere.
It's you need varied evidence.
I don't know how to,
I don't think it's easy to
describe exactly what's required,
but you need more than
high degree of certainty.
You need varied evidence,
so with evidence of different types,
and evidence that would
convince, that would, you know,
that many experts would
think would give you
an extremely high justification.
So just to give an example of
why high degree of
certainty is not enough,
in general I mean that, you know,
the famous lottery cases described by,
discussed by philosophers.
You have a lottery ticket.
You think you believe it's not gonna win.
There are maybe a million lottery tickets,
and, you know, you're right.
It's not. It doesn't win.
Did you know it?
Well, you didn't really know it,
even if your degree of
certainty was extremely high.
So I want to say that high
degree of certainty is very,
can help, but it's not enough.
You need to look at the quality.
It's not just the sort
of quantity, if you like,
the quality of the evidence,
but I do think that in
some cases, for example,
the case of the Goldbach conjecture,
probably we do have
that quality of evidence
as well as the quantity that's
sufficient for knowledge.
- Thanks.
So the next question is
from Alexander Meehan.
Thanks for a very clear talk.
I'm curious to hear more about
the connection between logic and inference
and what the bridge principles
are if there are any.
For example, I was
wondering if you could take
your arguments that logic is infinitiary
to show that deductive
inference is infinitiary,
and related, what would it mean to say
that deductive inference is infinitiary?
- Thank you, Alexander.
Good. I mean, I think these
are very difficult questions.
There are bridge principles
and it's actually an active
area of research in philosophy,
or epistemology more specifically,
to work out what are the bridge principles
between implication and inference
between logic and rational inference,
but it's actually quite tricky
to spell them out precisely.
So you might think it's something like,
well, if you believe the premises,
then you ought to believe the conclusion.
So it will be something along those lines,
but there's sort of
devil in the detail there
and it's hard to work
out precisely what it is,
but it's something along those lines.
As for the second part, deductive
inference is infinitary,
I've sort of did not want to
go that far, because as I said,
deductive inference is something agents do
and I find it hard, and yeah, you know,
superhumans can carry
out infinitary reasoning,
but we mere normal humans cannot,
and so if deductive inference
is very much tied to what we can do,
even somewhat idealized
versions of us, then I'm not,
I don't know if deductive
inference is infinitary.
I don't wanna go that far.
That's my answer.
- Yeah. Thank you.
So the question is about the
argument from topic neutrality.
I see that to be able to
characterize topic neutrality,
we need to make use of higher infinities,
but does this mean that our logic
needs to incorporate these infinities?
And another version of
the same question maybe,
is topic neutrality a neutral topic
or is this special to the topic of logic?
Is it tied, I guess, to logic, right?
- I see. Okay, thank you, Mark.
Right, so yeah.
So it's not so much that to
characterize topic neutrality,
we need to make use of higher infinities.
It's more that when we spell out
what topic neutrality means,
what kind of expressions
or what kind of relations
and properties are topic neutral,
they are the relations
that can be expressed
by an infinitary logic.
So it comes by way of discovery.
We're not using the higher infinities.
They sort of come out of the argument.
They tumble out of the argument,
or another way of putting
it, if you just think about
these infinite conjunctions
or disjunctions,
they preserve, eliminating conjunction,
infinitely many conjunctions
preserves topic neutrality.
It's not specific if you
want a concrete example.
It's not specific to
any particular domain.
So that's how the argument
goes from topic neutrality,
infinite, and highly
infinite logic falls out.
Another version of the same
question maybe you asked,
is topic neutrality a neutral topic
or is it special to the topic of logic?
Okay, that's a tricky one.
We've got some self-reflection
going on there.
Topic neutrality is a broad,
I don't know how to answer that directly,
but I'm not sure we need to.
Topic neutrality is a feature,
a characteristic of logic.
It is special to the topic
of logic. It doesn't apply.
I suppose the answer is
maybe straightforward.
I guess maybe I'm now thinking,
I now think it may be straightforward.
It is special to the topic of logic.
Other topics are not topic neutral.
You know, the law has a subject matter,
particle physics has a subject matter,
microeconomics has a
subject matter and so on,
but logic is, seems like it's
the only branch that has,
that is topic neutral.
- Yeah, so then there's
a question from Joel.
You distinguished
implication from inference
as apples and oranges, I think,
but wasn't your first
thesis about the first
and your second about the second?
- Yes.
(Priya laughing)
(laughing) Correct.
My first thesis was about implication
and my second one was about inference.
They are closely,
I want to be clear that they are distinct,
but I also want to say that
they are closely related,
and as I fessed up that my,
I wanted to align this with
the topic of this series,
so I snuck it into the title as inference.
They are related, but
they are, but nonetheless,
to be clear, they are distinct things.
- Are there any other questions?
Actually, Gila, if you have
a question, feel free to ask.
- And maybe I'll keep the
questions for next time,
but maybe just one small
thing about topic neutrality.
It is very common in philosophy to say
that a logic is topic neutral
because it doesn't have
a topic of its own,
but I think that this is not accurate.
Logic is topic neutral in
a logic does have a topic of its own
and that is logical implication
or logical inference.
No other discipline studies
this and logic studies this.
So that's definitely a
distinct topic that logic has,
but at the same time,
what is right about that
and why it's important
that logic is topic neutral
is that this topic, logical inference,
applies to all fields of knowledge
and so it applies to all topics.
It applies to all other topics
and that is because of
certain very special features
of logic that apply to all topics.
So, for example, physics
does not apply to numbers,
but logic applies both to
numbers and to physical objects.
So that's just a small comment.
- Yeah, thanks for that
clarifying comment.
So there is one more
question from Peter Morgan.
So a differential equation
can be a model for,
say, an electrical circuit or a pendulum.
Is that not topic neutral?
- Okay. Thank you, Peter.
So I would say that it's
not exactly topic neutral.
It's very general, but it's
not quite topic neutral.
To take the straightforward case,
maybe it's over the real numbers,
and so to differentiate a
function over the real numbers,
it's gotta be, you know,
a differentiable function,
so it has to have a pretty
specific kind of form.
It doesn't, the equation just can't apply
to any phenomenon whatsoever.
So it's very general, yes,
but not quite as general as logic.
- Right.
So that was an interesting question
to unpack, this, yeah.
That was-
- Absolutely, yeah.
Thank you, yeah.
- Thanks, Alex, yeah.
So we have another question
from Alexander Meehan.
So following up on a previous question,
it wasn't obvious to me how evidence
for the Goldbach conjecture
defers nature from evidence
for winning a lottery.
I have a different intuitive reaction,
but can you give me a
more principled argument?
It seemed to rely on diversity
of kinds of evidence.
- Yes, okay. So it's good.
So the, look, if the evidence for the,
okay, so the evidence for the
diversity of kinds of evidence
is crucial, I think, and
that is a big difference
from the lottery case,
to the lottery case,
and I think that's a
principle that we apply
in all sorts of, in all
spheres of reasoning, right?
I mean, for example, you know,
testing the boiling point of water.
I mean, if you, however
many times you test it,
if you don't vary certain
conditions, right,
if you don't vary the
pressure or the height
or we always do it in the same room,
then I don't think your
evidence is as good
as if you did it perhaps fewer times
but across a very
different range of contexts
and changing other variables.
So I think it is very relevant
that you have all sorts of
different types of evidence.
Now, the thing that I also
went over rather quickly,
admittedly, towards the end of the talk
was sort of more
philosophical considerations
for how you might convert this idea
of very strong and
diverse types of evidence
into just an outright claim of knowledge,
and I think really the onus is on someone
who doesn't think this
to try and defend it,
and the sorts of arguments
I gave there were, you know,
the kind of arguments
that have come up in,
the kind of ideas that
have come up in philosophy,
for example, the nature of knowledge.
Do you have, one sort of analysis
of the nature of what
knowledge is is a popular one,
which is not exactly right
but a sort of right track,
is that it's a reliable true belief, okay?
So if you have a true
belief about something
and it's acquired by a reliable method,
then that's knowledge.
Now, that's not quite right.
We know that from decades of epistemology,
but it's along the right lines,
and the method for
basing your mathematical,
for inferring Goldbach's conjecture
on this sort of evidence
is, I think, a reliable one,
and again, it's, you know,
I think it's important that there are
these heuristic arguments, right,
about the nature of the primes,
how many primes there are up to N,
and it would just be there's no reason,
and you speak to a
mathematician, you know,
and the mathematician would say,
"There'd be no reason
to expect it not to hold
given the distribution of the primes."
So there are sort of inherent reasons here
that go beyond just a lot of
cases, just sheer quantity.
- There is, there are
some follow-up question,
there's another follow-up question.
I'll (indistinct) with that.
I might have a diversity of evidence
that I won't win the lottery.
I've done many lotteries before and lost.
There are lots of tickets in this lottery.
I'm generally an unlucky
person, et cetera, et cetera,
and it seems that the
process of concluding
based on this kind of
evidence is a reliable one.
- Yes, okay. Good.
So the lottery cases show
that it can't quite be reliability.
There's gotta be more to
it than just reliability,
but again, but the lottery cases,
they're sort of insensitive
to whether you hold the
winning ticket or not.
I mean, you would still,
even if you held the winning
ticket, you would still believe
that you weren't gonna win the lottery,
assuming you believe that
you didn't win the lottery.
Just to get the structure of
the alleged counterexample here,
you're saying, "Well,
in the lottery cases,
we don't want to say we
have reliable true belief
that we're not gonna win,
but the thought is we
don't have knowledge,"
and that's correct, but
it's also insensitive
to whether you have knowledge
to whether you hold a
winning ticket or not,
because if you did by chance
hold the winning ticket,
you would still think the same things,
but the mathematical case isn't like that.
If Goldbach's conjecture were false,
and that's a very hard thing to spell out,
but we would expect quite
different sorts of evidence
is the idea.
- Right.
So actually, I wanna go back to this point
that you made about the, you know,
our conception of the nature of knowledge
and how reliable true beliefs,
so if you look at physics,
right, so you are inherently,
knowledge is inherently provisional.
So are you making a claim that
mathematical knowledge is,
doesn't have that kind of provisionality?
That it's reliable, I mean,
that reliability is uppercase R somehow?
- No, in fact, I'm very drawn
to a more scientific picture
of mathematical knowledge,
and in a way that's why I'm,
that's part of what's
in the background here.
- Okay. Yeah.
- That I think mathematics is a bit more,
at least a bit more like science,
natural science, than most people think,
and of course this sort
of non-deductive reasoning
is all over the place in science.
- Right.
- Yeah, and I think the
history of mathematics
shows that mathematics, I mean,
it's more cumulative than science,
but it's not entirely cumulative.
You know, there are
revolutions in mathematics.
There are things that we believed,
that everyone believed, you know,
that all numbers were positive,
or all numbers were real for centuries,
or that, you know, the parallel postulate,
or Euclid in one of
his common notions says
that the whole is bigger than its parts.
Actually, set theory and one way
of understanding that disproves that.
So I do not, I don't have
that picture of mathematics
as sort of eternal in
that way, in (indistinct).
- Yeah, and that's, okay,
now that kind of fits while,
so that's why you're making a claim,
sort of you're making the
sort of distinguishing between
sort of deductive and the
non-deductive part of, okay,
so you're kind of making room
for a more provisional, yeah, okay.
- Absolutely, so I want to, I'm drawn,
I'm trying to assimilate
mathematics to science
because that's where I think it is closer
to science than we think.
- Okay.
- [Alex] In its method.
Okay, are there any other questions?
I'll just give another minute
if anyone has a last minute question,
but thank you so much,
Alex, that was fantastic,
and thanks for patiently taking
all these questions and clarifying.
I learned a lot and it's
very interesting to see
that you are trying to construct
a view of knowledge in mathematics
that actually aligns it much better
with sort of knowledge creation
and knowledge in the
sciences, and I wonder,
you know, the sort of,
the next kind of barrier,
right, if you will,
or the next threshold to cross, right,
so is, you know, in scientific knowledge,
in physics and in many
other disciplines, right,
is experiential and experimental, right?
So there is room for sort
of empirical investigation.
Do you see what is the portal
that is opening up in mathematics
that takes you somewhere near there
or is it a very different
kind of provisionality
that doesn't sort of go in that direction?
- Yeah, I mean, there is
a field of mathematics
which is known as
experimental mathematics,
and there it's, there's lots of things
like probabilistic proofs and, you know,
the kind of arguments that I discussed.
So I mean, it could be,
I mean, one of the things, okay,
one of the things that you,
one of the types of
evidence that I've described
is like what's known as
inductive evidence, right?
You just have more.
You have a lot of As that are Bs
and you infer that As are Bs.
So that's typical of science,
but you also get another more
subtle form of argument form,
more subtle form of argument
that happens in science,
which is inference of
the best explanation.
You get different phenomena and then they,
you can find one explanation
that covers them,
and the classic example is
Newton's theory of gravity
unifying celestial and terrestrial
mechanics, for example.
Okay, and I see that as also
applying in mathematics.
You've got disparate phenomena
in different areas of mathematics
and then you can find a unifying theory
that makes sense of them.
Making sense in this way in mathematics
will usually be implying them, right?
- Right.
- So you've got phenomena
in area A, phenomena in area B,
and then you find area C
that somehow encompasses both
and entails the results in
area A and in an area B,
but it's the same sort of thing
looked at through a general lens.
It's something that
allows you to make sense-
- I mean, I would, yeah,
I would, I'd buy your
argument for the purposes
of thinking about progress, right?
So what is progress?
When are you accumulating new knowledge?
So I see the analogy
that you just gave works,
aligns very well with physics, right?
You often say that, you know,
Einstein's theory of general relativity
reduces to the Newtonian case,
but it's a more general sort of,
it's more sort of a larger
covering theory, right?
So the explanatory domain is much larger
compared to sort of Newton's
theory of gravitation, right?
So I see that that is sort of
what you are invoking, right?
That there could be larger covering.
Area C could sort of cover and encompass
multiple existing domains,
but would you, but I mean,
I guess the question, that
begs the question, right,
in physics that would be progress.
That would be a measure of progress
and of accumulation of
new knowledge, right?
So is there the same notion of progress
then built into the accumulation
of mathematical knowledge?
- I would argue that yes.
I mean, in short, yeah,
and this is one of the
ways in which you get,
that progress takes place.
You find a larger area
that encompasses areas
that you knew about before.
I mean, an example from
19th century algebra
is the development of group
theory, which was, you know,
Galois and the work of
Galois was really about
finding solutions to polynomial equations,
but then it turned out to
have all sorts of applications
outside that context and so it,
there was a kind of general theory
of groups that could develop, emerge,
that could encompass lots
of different phenomena
in mathematics, not just-
- Not just.
- [Alex] Solutions of polynomials.
- Great.
So there's one final question
before we let you go.
Is deductive logic
non-deductive? (laughing)
(Alex laughing)
(indistinct) some circular loops.
- I don't how to answer that, Joel.
I think deductive logic
is deductive logic.
It's deductive is what I'm gonna say.
I'm gonna just, I'm just
gonna repeat it. (laughing)
- Great.
Okay. Great.
So if there are no further questions,
let's all thank Alex for a fantastic talk
and a thought-provoking talk,
and we look forward
tomorrow to the conversation
between Alex and Gila.
Thank you, everyone, for
coming and see you tomorrow
at the same time, at 3:00 pm Eastern.
- Thank you so much, Priya,
and thanks to everyone
for their questions.
- Yeah. Thank you.